you
good afternoon and welcome to
pennsylvania mr president
my name is mike fiore and i'm a senior
line worker from duquesne light and a
proud member of the international
brotherhood of electrical workers local
29
right here in pittsburgh from day one of
this pandemic me and my co-workers have
been on the front lines
it's my job there's no working from home
we've kept the lights on and the power
running to communities throughout
western pennsylvania every day i deal
with our electrical grid
so i know how critical infrastructure is
to our communities
that's why i'm so excited about joe
biden's buildback better plan
nearly everyone agrees that we need to
modernize our roads bridges
power grids airports and railroads
that we need to invest in new energy
technologies in american-made
manufacturing
but what president biden is proposing
isn't just an investment in
infrastructure
it's an investment in good union jobs
it's an investment in good schools
and strong communities it's an
investment in the future of so many
forgotten paths in america
my brother teaches at pine ridgeland
high school and gives saudi arabia just
over here
the same high school both went to the
kind of investment john
is talking about would mean so much to
his school
both and in the years to come for
example president obama
high-speed broadband and that's critical
to the health of so many small towns in
this area
i've got two little kids at home myself
and i don't want to see them leave the
area or even the state to find
opportunities
the buildback better plan is directed at
communities like mine
it's about opening up opportunities
revitalizing local businesses
and creating jobs for decades
pennsylvania was a global leader in
manufacturing of good union jobs
it can be that way again as president
biden has a solid plan to make that
happen
i also don't want my kids growing up in
a world where the threat of climate
change hangs over their heads
that means investing in electrical
vehicle charging infrastructures
in all forms of clean power technology
so we can slash carbon emissions and
create tens of thousands of green energy
jobs
union jumps and that's exactly what
president biden is proposing
here's another reason i'm so excited
about this i'm 100
a union guy it is in my blood the union
changed my life
and it gave me opportunities i could
never have dreamed
being a line worker isn't always easy
but thanks to my union
i enjoy a great paycheck strong health
and retirement benefits
and a voice on the job
here's who else is a union guy joe biden
and he said again and again
unions built the middle class that's why
his plan supports collective bargaining
rights
it supports a living wage and making
sure the taxpayer money goes to
supporting american-made manufacturing
the men and women of the ibew are ready
to get to work rebuilding our
infrastructure
retooling our plants and revitalizing
our communities and the middle class
we're ready to build america back better
so it is my pleasure
and it is my honor to introduce the
president of the united states
joe biden
thank you
mike asked me and say to
bobby my good friend he asked me back
there he said do you ever get nervous
and i he said because i got up this
morning made breakfast with my kids
so i got introduced to president and
well i said you mike you did a heck of a
job
but i'd get nervous if i had to get up
in the middle of the night climb up a
telephone pole
replaced in the middle of a storm a
connection that knocked out everybody's
electricity put a transformer that's
what
would make me nervous so what you did
was really good i couldn't do what you
do pal
i couldn't do what you do and uh i want
to uh
and it's true mike you're a union guy me
too
i got in trouble but i don't make any
apologies for it
i'm a union guy i support unions unions
built the middle class it's about time
they start to get
piece of the action to all my colleagues
[Applause]
from the county executive the mayor
everyone that's here i want to say
thank you thank you congressman for the
for the
passport in your district and i
appreciate
being here uh i'm honored to be with you
two years ago i began my campaign here
in pittsburgh
and i was running to rebuild the
backbone of america
today i return as your president
to lay out the vision of how i believe
we do that
rebuild the backbone of america it's a
vision
not seen through the eyes of wall street
or washington
but through the eyes of hard-working
people like the people i grew up with
people like mike and his union family
union workers and this carpenter's
training center
people like the folks i grew up with in
scranton and claim on delaware
people will get up every day work hard
raise their family pay their taxes
serve their country and volunteer for
their communities
and just looking for a little bit of
breathing room just a little bit of
light
ordinary americans doing extraordinary
things
people who break their necks every day
for their families and the country they
love
the country that in fact
which on the day i was elected was in
extreme distress
with the virus on a deadly rampage that
is now
killed over four thousand excuse me
500 i carried in my pocket every day
i have the list of exactly how many have
died
547
296 americans
dead from the virus
more than all the people killed in world
war one
world war ii the vietnam war
911 547
296 americans and an economy
that left millions out of work
and created so much anxiety
that's why i moved so quickly to pass
the american rescue plan with the help
of
my friends here in the congress i really
mean that
it didn't pass by a whole lot but with
the leadership of
connor and bobby and the mayor
just you got it done
because it was an emergency
we needed to act to save jobs
to save businesses to save lives
and that's what we did we're beginning
to see the results
we're on our way to having given 200
million vaccination shots
in the first 100 days of my presidency
when i said i'd get 100 million done
people thought it was a significant
exaggeration
we're going to get 200 million done
twice the original goal
because of all the help of all of you
leading economists
are now predicting our economy will grow
six percent this year
that's a rate we haven't seen in years
and years
we can cut child poverty in half this
year
with the american rescue plan we're
meeting
immediate emergencies now it's time to
rebuild
even before the christ
those at the very top in america were
doing
very well which is fine they were doing
great
but everyone else was falling behind
the pandemic only made the division so
much worse and more obvious
millions of americans lost their jobs
last year
while the wealthiest one percent of
americans saw their
net worth increase by 4
trillion dollars
just goes to show you how distorted and
unfair our economy has become
wasn't always this way well it's time to
change that
i know parenthetically that i got
criticized
for giving tax breaks to middle class
and poor folks this last time
i didn't hear that cry you and cry
when we were doing the same thing when
trump's
tax bill passed 83 of the money went to
the top
one percent
you know this is not to target those who
made it
and not to seek retribution this is
about opening
opportunities for everybody else
here's the truth we all will do better
when we all do well
it's time to build our economy from the
bottom up and from the middle out
not the top down it hadn't worked very
well
for the economy overall it hadn't worked
because wall street didn't build this
country you
great middle class built this country
and unions
built the middle class
and it's time and this time
when we rebuild the middle class we're
going to bring everybody along
regardless your background your color
your religion the way
everybody gets to come along so today
i'm proposing a plan for the nation that
rewards work
not just rewards wealth it builds a fair
economy that gives
everybody a chance to succeed and it's
going to create the strongest most
resilient
innovative economy in the world
it's not a plan that tinkers around the
edges
it's a once-in-a-generation investment
in america unlike
anything we've seen or done
since we built the interstate highway
system and the space race decades ago
in fact it's the largest american jobs
investment
since world war ii will create
millions of jobs good paying jobs we'll
grow the economy
make us more competitive around the
world promote our national security
interests
and put us in a position to win the
global competition with
china in the upcoming years it's
big yes it's bold yes
and we can get it done it has two parts
the american jobs plan and the american
families plan
both are essential to our economic
future in a few weeks
i'll talk about the americans family
plan but today
i want to talk about the americans jobs
plan
i'll begin with the heart of the plan
it modernizes transportation
infrastructure
our roads our bridges our airports i
just left your airport
the director of the airport said we're
about to renovate the airport is that
right
mr county executive we're going to
innovate we're going to
employ thousands of people and she
looked at me said i can't thank you
enough
for this plan
it grows the economy in key ways
it puts people to work to repair and
upgrade
that we badly need it makes it easier
and more efficient to move goods
to get to work and to make us more
competitive
around the world some of you local
officials know when someone wants to
come in the area and
the company wants to invest what do they
ask where's the first rail bed how can i
get to the railroad
what access interstate do i have what's
the water like
tell me about it goes on and on it's
about infrastructure
the american jobs plan will modernize
modernizing 20
000 miles of highways roads and main
streets
that are in difficult difficult shape
right now
it'll fix the nation's 10 most
economically significant
bridges in america that require
replacement
remember that bridging went down we got
10
most economically significant bridges
with more commerce going across it
that need to be replaced
we'll also repair ten thousand bridges
desperately needed upgrades to unclog
traffic keep people safe and connect our
cities towns
and tribes across the american jobs plan
will build
new rail corridors and transit lines
easing congestion
cutting pollution slashing commute times
and opening up investment in communities
that became connected to the cities
and cities to the outskirts where a lot
of jobs are these days
it reduced the bottlenecks of commerce
at our ports and our airports
the american jobs plan will lead to a
transformational progress
an effort to tackle climate change with
american jobs and american ingenuity
protect our community from billions of
dollars of damage from historic
super storms floods wildfires droughts
year after year by making our
infrastructure more secure and resilient
and seizing incredible opportunities for
american workers and american farmers
in a clean energy future skilled workers
like one we just heard from building a
nationwide
wide network of 500 000 charging
stations
creating good-paying jobs by leading the
world in the manufacturing and export
of clean electric cars and trucks
we're going to provide tax incentives
and point of sale rebirth
rebates to help all american families
afford clean vehicles of the future the
federal government owns an enormous
fleet of vehicles
which are going to be transitioned to
clean electric vehicles and hydrogen
vehicles
right here in the united states america
by american workers with american
products
when we make all of these investments
we're going to make sure
as the executive order i signed early on
that we
buy america
that means investing in american-based
companies and american workers
not a contract will go out that i
control
that will not go to a company
that is an american company with
american products
all the way down the line and american
workers
and we'll buy the goods we need from all
of america
communities that have historically been
left out of these investments
black latino asian american native
americans rural
small businesses entrepreneurs across
the country
look today up to 10 million homes in
america and more than
400 000 schools and child care centers
have pipes where they get their water
from
pipes that are lead-based pipes
including pipes for drinking water
according to scientists
there is simply no safe exposure to lead
for a child that can slow development
and hearing problems american jobs plan
will put plumbers and pipefitters to
work
replacing 100
of the nation's lead pipes and service
lines so
every american every child
can turn on a faucet of our fountain and
drink clean water
with these five thousand dollar
investment
replacing the line that can mean up to
twenty two
thousand dollars in health care cost
saved a chance to protect our children
help them learn and thrive
we can't delay we can't delay another
minute
it's long past due you know in america
where the early interest
was in internet this thing called the
internet that we invested we
we invented the early early internet
was invented here millions of americans
though
lack access to reliable high-speed
internet
including more than 35 percent of rural
america
it's a disparity even more pronounced
during this pandemic
american jobs will make sure
every single every single american
has access to high quality affordable
high-speed internet
for businesses for schools
when i say affordable i mean it
americans pay
too much for internet service we're
going to drive down the price for
families
who have service now and make it easier
for families who don't have affordable
service to be able to get it
now as we saw in texas and elsewhere
our electrical power and power grids are
vulnerable to storms
catastrophic failures and security
lapses
with tragic results my american jobs
plan will put hundreds of thousands of
people to work hundreds of thousands of
people to work
line workers electricians and laborers
laying thousands of miles of
transmission line building a modern
resilient
and fully clean grid and capping
hundreds of thousands of
or literally orphan oil and gas wells
that need to be cleaned up because
they're abandoned
paying the same exact rate that a union
man or woman would get having dug that
well in the first place
we'll build upgrade and weatherize
affordable
energy efficient housing commercial
buildings
for millions of americans even before
the pandemic
million working families faced enormous
enormous financial
and personal strain trying to raise
their kids and care for their parents at
the same time
the so-called sandwich generation or
family members with disability
got a child at home you can't stay home
from work to take care of that child
unless you lose you're gonna the child's
at risk or you lose your job
or you have an elderly parent you're
taking care of
and seniors and people with disabilities
living independently
feel that strain as well but we know if
they can remain independently living
they live longer
american jobs plan is going to help in
big ways it's going to extend
access to quality affordable home
community-based care
think of expanded vital services like
programs for seniors
or think of home care workers going into
homes of seniors
and people with disabilities cooking
meals helping them get around their
homes
and helping them be able to live more
independently
for too long caregivers who are
disproportionately women are women of
color and immigrants
this plan along with american families
plan changes that
with better wages benefits and
opportunities for millions of people
who will be able to get to work in an
economy that works for them
you know decades ago the united states
government used to spend
two percent of its gdp its gross
domestic product
on research and development
today we spend less than one percent i
think it's seven
tenths of one percent
here's why that matters we're one of
only a few major economies in the world
who public investment and research and
development
as the share of dj gdp has declined
constantly over the last 25 years
and we've fallen back the rest of the
world is closing in and closing in
fast we can't allow this to continue
american jobs plan is the biggest
increase in our federal
non-defense research and development
spending on record
it's going to boost america's innovative
edge
in markets where global leadership is up
for grabs
markets like battery technology
biotechnology
computer chips clean energy a
competition with china in particular
critics say we shouldn't spend this
money
they ask what do we get out of it
well they said the same thing we first
flew into space for the first time
they said the same thing well pushing
the frontiers
led the big benefits back home when nasa
created apollo's digital flight control
system
unheard of at the time it led to
technologies that helped us today to
drive
our cars and fly our planes when nasa
invented ways to keep food safe for the
astronauts
it led to programs that have been used
to for decades to keep food safe in
supermarkets
at least 2 000 products and services
have been developed
and commercialized as a result of
american space exploration
gps has helped us find each other
computer chips allow us to see and talk
to one another
even separated by mountains and oceans
singing happy birthday and watching the
first steps of that new baby grandchild
comforting each other when comfort is
needed
think about what it means to you and
your loved ones
we just have to imagine again i had a
long discussion with xi jinping
leader of china and he called to
congratulate we
spent two hours on the phone
and he said it was astonished my
national security team and the china
experts were on the line
he said you've always said mr president
that you can define america in one word
possibilities that's who we are
in america anything's possible
like what we did with vaccines a decade
ago that laid the foundation for covet
19 vaccines we had today
like we did when the interstate highway
system that transformed the way we
traveled
lived worked and developed
americans could visit relatives anywhere
in the country
with just a family station wagon
business here in pittsburgh
could load up a truck get a product of
portland or phoenix
to this day about a quarter of all the
miles
americans drive each year on one of
those very original highways
imagine what we can do what's within our
reach we modernize those highways
you and your family can travel coast to
coast without a single
tank of gas on board a high-speed train
and connect high-speed affordable
reliable internet wherever you live
imagine knowing that you are handing
your children and grandchildren
a country that will lead the world on
producing clean energy technology
and will need to address one of the
biggest threats of our time
that's what we'll do all together along
with the american rescue plan
proposal i put forward will create
millions of jobs
estimated by some wall street outfits
over 18 million jobs over four years
good paying jobs it also works to level
the playing field and power workers and
ensure that
new jobs are good jobs that you can
raise a family on
and ensure free and fair choice to
organize and bargain collectively
that's why my plan asked congress to
pass the protecting the right to
organize
act the pro-act and send it to my desk
this plan is important not only for what
and how it builds
but also important to where we build it
includes everyone regardless of your
race your
zip code too often economic growth and
recovery is concentrated on the coast
too often investments have failed to
meet the needs of marginalized
communities left behind
there is talent innovation everywhere
and this plan connects that talent
through cities small towns rural
communities
through our businesses and our
universities through our entrepreneurs
union workers all across america
we have to move now because i'm
convinced
that we act now in 50 years people are
going to look back and say
this was the moment that america
won the future
what i am proposing is a one-time
capital investment of roughly two
trillion dollars in america's future
spread largely over eight years
will generate historic job growth
historic economic growth
help businesses to compete
internationally create more revenue as
well
they're among the highest value
investments we can make in the nation
investing in our infrastructure
but put another way failing to make
these investments adds to our debt
and effectively puts our children at a
disadvantage relative our competitors
that's what crumbling infrastructure
does
and our infrastructure is crumbling
ranked 13th in the world
what's more it heightens our
vulnerability
to uh it attack attracts our adversaries
to compete in ways that they don't have
them up to now
and our adversaries are worried about us
building this critical infrastructure
put simply
these are investments we have to make we
can
afford to make them put another we can't
afford not to
so how do we pay for it
i spoke to the majority leader and no
longer
i guess he's no longer the majority
leader you guys met for a long time
i spoke for a republican i spoke to the
republican leader about the plan
everybody's for doing something on
infrastructure why have we done it
well no one wants to pay for it less
than four years ago
as i said the congress passed a tax cut
of two trillion dollars increasing the
national debt two trillion dollars
it didn't meet purchasing any of the
predictions that would in terms of
growing the economy
overwhelmingly the benefits of that tax
package went to the wealthiest americans
it even included new investments that
would you
profit by shifting profits and jobs
overseas if you're a corporation
it was bad for american competitors
deeply unfair to the middle class
families
wrong for our future so here's what i do
i start with one rule no one
who say it again no one making under
four hundred thousand dollars
will see their federal taxes go up
period
this is not about penalizing anyone
i have nothing against millionaires and
billionaires i believe
american american capitalism i want
everyone to do well
but here's the deal right now a
middle-class couple
a firefighter and a teacher with two
kids
making a combined salary of say 110 120
000 a year pays 22
cents for each additional dollar they
earn in federal income tax
but a multinational corporation that
builds a factory abroad
brings it homes and sells they pay
nothing at all
we're going to raise the corporate tax
it was
35 percent which was too high we all
agreed
five years ago it should go down to 28
but they reduced it to 21 we're gonna
raise it back to
up to 28 no one should be able to
complain about that
it's still lower than what that rate was
between world war
ii and 2017. just doing that one thing
will generate one trillion dollars in
additional revenue over 15 years
in 2019 an independent analysis found
that there are
91. let me say it again 91 fortune
500 companies biggest companies in the
world
including amazon that use various
loopholes so they pay
not a single solitary penny
in federal income tax i don't want to
punish him that's just
wrong that's just wrong
fireman teacher paying 22
amazon and 90 other major corporations
paying zero in federal taxes
i'm going to put an end to that here's
how we'll do it
we're establishing a global minimum tax
for u.s corporations at 21
we're going to level the international
playing field that alone will raise
1 trillion over 15 years
we'll also eliminate deductions by
corporations for offshoring jobs
and shifting assets overseas you do that
you pay a penalty you don't get a reward
in my plan and use the savings from that
to give companies tax credits
to locate manufacturing here in
manufacturing and production here in the
united states
i will significantly ramp up the irs
enforcement against corporations
who either fail to report their incomes
or under report it's estimated that
could raise hundreds of billions of
dollars
all this adds up to more than what i
proposed
to spend in just 15 years it's honest
it's fiscally responsible and by the way
as the experts will tell you it reduces
the debt
the federal debt over the long haul let
me be clear
these are my ideas and how to pay for
this plan
others have additional ideas let them
come forward
i'm open to other ideas so long as they
do not impose any tax increase on people
making less than four hundred thousand
dollars let me close with this
historically infrastructure had been a
bipartisan undertaking
many times led by republicans it was
abraham lincoln
who built the transcontinental railroad
dwight eisenhower republican the
interstate highway system
i could go on and i don't think you'll
find a republican
today in the house or senate maybe i'm
wrong gentlemen who doesn't think we
have to improve our infrastructure
they know china and other countries are
eating our lunch
so there's no reason why i can't be
bipartisan again
the divisions of the moment shouldn't
stop us from doing the right thing for
the future
i'm going to bring republicans into the
oval office
listen to them what they have to say and
be open to other ideas
we'll have a good faith negotiation with
any republican who wants to help get
this done
but we have to get it done
i truly believe we're in a moment
history is going to look back on this
time
as a fundamental choice having been made
between democracies and autocracies
you know there's a lot of autocrats in
the world who think the reason why
they're going to win
is democracies can't reach consensus any
longer
autocracies do that's what competition
between
america and china and the rest of the
world is all about
it's a basic question can democracy
still deliver for their people can they
get a majority
i believe we can i believe we must
delivering for the american people is
what the american rescue plan was all
about
and it's been overwhelmingly popular
when i wrote it
everybody said i had no bipartisan
support or
overwhelming bipartisan port were
republican registered republican voters
and ask around if you live in a town
with a republican mayor
republican county executive or
republican governor ask them
how many would rather get rid of the
plan
ask them if it helped them at all
it's what the american job plan is about
the new one i'm proposing i hope
republicans and congress will join this
effort
i hope and i believe a number of
businesses will join this effort
and i hope and believe the american
people will join this effort
democrats republican independents we can
do this
we have to do this we will do this
we just have to remember this is the
united states of america
and i've said it a thousand times
there's nothing beyond our capacity if
we act together
so it's time to move together thank you
and i hope
i get to come back to see you folks
after this plan has passed and the
question is
you have to attract even more
apprentices
more people because we're building so
much
god bless you all may god protect our
church thank you
you